[Music]
hello welcome everyone my name is Dave
Lor I'm going to be talking to you in
this presentation about THC inflation
and the phenomenon known as lab
shopping first start off a little bit
about myself and my qualifications for
for giving this presentation um I have
experience with four different
analytical testing Labs as a lab
director in three different states two
of those were in California one in
Oregon and one in New Mexico of course
all those States operate under different
state
regulations my scientific background is
I have a bachelor's in
Biochemistry master m in
microbiology and a PhD in biology focus
on molecular biology and
zoology joining industry I had a long
career in life sciences a lot of that
work was field applications
scientist support troubleshooting and
training in Labs throughout the United
States for different uh scientific
groups that provided tools for for
researchers I've also worked in the
human ident ification testing field
human relationship testing and as you
can imagine all these different
Industries groups have their different
Quality
Systems most recently since uh my last
full-time position in uh the lab
director spot I've been um developing
some businesses of my own one thing I'm
focusing on is a new startup oh looking
at cannabis DNA specific applications
that looks like an
underserved Market to to myself and
that's called ganja genomics and a brand
new entity we're starting with a partner
very soon it's called DNA is
love um just wanted to give a little
disclaimer too in this talk that uh all
the comments I'll make here are really
my personal opinion and feedback from
other scientists uh business people I've
spoken to um not any
specific uh calling out of any group or
individual for any of these this is
obviously a little bit of a contentious
topic that we'll talk about
here so for the session overview here's
kind of what I would like to try to get
across and we'll discuss a little bit um
first is kind of the science of THC
testing you know what the molecule
looked like what the chemistry of it is
that I then want to spend some time and
talk about the
situation and the background of these
analytical testing labs and the
situation that they find themselves
under um it's potent testing that we're
talking about but there's a whole
spectrum of testing that needs to be
done for State
compliance so we'll discuss that a
little
bit then I'll get into the nitty-gritty
what exactly is lab shopping and this
THC inflation and then what are some of
the ways that Growers and the labs have
tried to gain an advantage or more or
less
cheat I'll discuss some ways people and
companies are reacting to these
uh changes these situations that come up
these unfair competitive
advantages and then finally I'll propose
some solutions for the field to help get
back on the
path uh where everything is more Level
Playing Field
so first off let me start with a little
bit of the science behind this um as
many people know many of the research
and scientific people in this field that
the major cannaboids there's a couple
different metabolic
pathways uh CBD and THC there's a a
standard form in an acidic form and they
have the same precursor
molecules this shows that pathway that
THC and CBD follow and again you could
see they uh Branch
off at the midpoint here and they have a
different endpoint uh molecule so these
are the chemistry differences that we're
looking at and a typical potency profile
where we're looking at 10 to 15 um
upwards of 16 to 18 uh different
cannabinoids which will come off on the
hplc next I want to talk about the an
overview of the potency testing process
itself
so hlc is the instrument of choice for
doing this and that stands for high
performance liquid
chromatography it gives the most
accurate in-depth profile available for
the different cannabis types and this
can also be from the different starting
materials so all all products that will
go into stores dispensaries need to get
tested for a range of chemical
properties um those are the cannabinoids
right and then but also um residual
solvents if it's a processed
uh like oil or tincture that type of
thing um pesticides all products um
heavy metals and again these U may vary
a little bit the menu of testing will
vary a little bit from state to
state so back to potency um first really
couple steps in the process is the hplc
calibration getting to an operational
phase and then training on the hplc
there's actually just a couple of um
noted vendors in this field I'm not
going to really name names in this talk
um but you know if anybody that's worked
in this knows who kind of the couple
providers are there's a little more
high-end uh solution in terms of
instruments and software a little more
affordable solution that type of thing
so then the actual process starts with
uh the sampling I'm going to talk quite
a bit about the sampling in in a couple
slides um you know the weighing of the
correct amount of the material and this
is all for the lab you know Sops
standard operating procedures right and
then a chemical extraction takes place
usually it's a methanol and dilution
type of
procedure once that happens the sample
along with the days rest of the day
batch will get injected into the hlc and
there's usually an auto sampler
uh and then the samples will be
processed in the order that they are are
run after that the process will be like
automated data analysis and then there
is a chance to do manual data override
which is something else we'll talk a
little bit
about um and again the hlc is capable of
testing all those different canono that
you're seeing on the slide here so Delta
9 Delta 8 thcv so forth all the C BD
derivatives for example and then you
know anything that's to be added to the
standard list is a more methods
validation process um different
cannabinoids can be added you know at
any point in time um through a
validation and
revalidation um as
necessary here's sort of just a little
bit of a view of what you know this
equipment looks like so here's an hlc
from a vendor it's a little bit of a
white box there's some definitely some
different pumps inside um pressure and
then the key of of the whole thing is a
column so it's chomatography
basically and um you know the chemicals
to go through and then the
software will give you um the Peaks and
I'll show you an example of data here
that comes off in just a
moment
all right so here's a schematic here's
just a view of a cannabinoid profile by
H PLC and what you'll basically see is a
series of Peaks
here and what these Peaks are during the
chromatography process these are held
onto the column for different amount of
what's called retention time and that
separates the different compounds from
each other sometimes this is nice clear
easy to use separation sometimes it
needs work and fine-tuning to optimize
the method so all that work gets rolled
into what's called a validation process
as it goes through the state uh approval
process for these different states
basically you want a
reproducible standardized procedure that
can handle the different types of
samples and a very
reproducible clear easy to discriminate
way right and again the software will
mostly do this for you but it does allow
you to uh
modify change things right so those
changes are one of the things we talk
about you know as a potential for what
gets called as this what gets called as
that what gets changed around a little
bit one thing with uh the Cannabis
Testing field is is really relatively
compared to other fields compared to
food testing compared to Medical
Diagnostics it's in its
infancy so the regulations the
requirements the quality systems for
this are more of a work in
progress as everyone knows there are no
national standards at this point so
there are different state
specific
certifications some Labs many Labs try
to go on and Achieve ISO
accreditation um that's generally a work
in process for a startup
lab and you know from my experience the
there's quite a variation in the uh lab
quality lab
systems and really some of these are
kind of borrowed and uh taken and
modified from other Industries um the
thing that's is always to keep in mind
with cannabis is it's a relatively very
complex compound and class of compounds
there's so many different types of some
materials in each sample carbohydrates
fats
lipids DNA and on and on and also all
the cannabinoids
tpin flavonoids all those type of
compounds so it's a very very
complex Matrix compared to what is often
tested in other
fields it's important that everything in
the lab is calibrated properly so all
the instruments
balances
pipets and you know the use of
appropriate certified reference
materials is really important standard
setting um as the you know as the first
potency calibration and so forth gets
done it needs to be accurate and precise
to start with so that's where the
starting point for the the whole
validation process
begins you know most States again
there's some differences from state to
state and I'm going to definit talk
about the regulations and how that all
fits in the whole THC inflation process
here so just again giving you a little
bit of a baseline on this um you know
the methods include accuracy precision
um limit of detection and quantitation
those are two slightly different but but
a little bit similar process basically
how low can you measure because a lot of
these compounds are going to be in a
very very low
amount then how reproducible is it how
it does it look when you're looking with
multiple analysts with the same
procedure the same samples all those
things so it actually becomes like weeks
months
long
process and really kind of new to the
field as just emerging too but um all
Labs all labs and those other industries
that I've talked about really you want
to do some type of proficiency testing
programs maybe lab sharing of samples
back and forth really any anything you
do do to improve your quality metrics
and show the quality of data that comes
off um is is definitely a
benefit so this is my experience from
working at Several of these Cannabis
Testing labs and what I want to get
across here is that on top of the whole
Lab shopping issue these are
very difficult
um situations to start to deal with
right first of all it takes a huge
investment to get a lab up and running
um the first thing is the facilities
need to be on topnotch electrical hbac
for example or
complex the
instrumentations is very cost costly I
mean it can actually take a million to
maybe $1.5 Million worth of investment
because not only are you having to pick
up an hplc but you need an icpms for
Metals testing you need G GC GC triple
quad LC triple quad and qpcr for those
other
testing menus on the on the list that
need to be in so between the instruments
service contracts you know chemicals
consumables it's a very costly process
to start and own and run a
laboratory another difficulty is really
just getting trained staff um to to run
some of these instrumentation as as the
field expands as the number of
people increase and the number of labs
increase there are only so many
qualified chemists that have the
background to do this well and step in
on it again as I mentioned cannabis is a
is a complex Matrix so it's it's
difficult it's kind of challenging to
work
with and the other thing is they not
that many people yet who've moved across
have stepped away from mainstream
Industries to get into the Cannabis
field CU once you move in that direction
it may not be that easy to move
back and in be due to that there's
really been quite a bit of high turnover
um for lab director quality chemist
positions you know it's been some
definite turnover which is part of a
little bit of the issue of the whole
field I in my
estimation another Factor the labs have
to deal with is a limb system so we need
integration on the software on the it
end from when a sample gets ordered um
to be picked up and
collected all the way through the lab
processing through the generation of
what's called a certificate of analysis
so COA which is basically the
results and through the entire process
with including all the data so that's
another big lift for the labs so most of
these labs are um under staff kind of
under Financial stress
and they've been through this validation
process and
in my experience all the labs I've been
at the length and the complexity of that
validation is
underappreciated um and I also do think
there's a little bit of a disconnect
between the state
regulations The Regulators and the labs
in terms of what's required so it's a
bit of a interpretation guessing game um
and I think that's the education on both
sides of the fence that kind of leads to
that
point okay the next thing I want to add
to this um there's so there's some
things we should discuss one is there's
natural biological variation between the
samples um I want to talk about for a
minute the effect of the regulations on
this and then you know taking it all the
way to the spectrum of intentional
manipulation of of data that's what
we're kind of talking about from you
know and it's a range of what is causing
discrepancies in THC
values so again first of all um cannabis
is a very complex Dynamic plant there
are many factors where the THC level can
vary and the CBD all can avonoid levels
can vary so basically a a lab test at a
given point in time is kind of a single
snapshot
and really it's an N of one so it's
there's going to be some bias to a
single
sample and you know crucially important
and I'll talk to you in a minute too is
the sampling process itself so how are
you guaranteeing that you're taking a
reproducible homogeneous mixture of the
sample that that is for this entire
batch which is can be a pretty large
amount of material and again mostly in
in this kind of uh sampling thing we're
talking about flour right because once
the thing is processed say an edible or
something it's a much more homogeneous
mix uh the flower itself is kind of
where the complexity of the biology
mostly comes into
play one thing I want to just say is um
that you know it's really all testing
that's being done is compared to the
alternative there right which is the
black market which is no testing so all
testing is good testing in the right
direction but it has to be to the best
of our scientific knowledge and again
this Fair playing field and that's where
you know the entire process of
the lab shopping comes into play and and
I think this kind of starts at a
Grassroots level right so it's the
consumer out there saying I want to have
the highest THC amount I'm going to get
the best high and for the least price
that's what they're after they're after
the most bang the most Buzz they can get
for their buck in effect and as the
science is coming out here we are in
2023 there people are finding out
there's a lot more to the experience
right for the health for the
wellness the recreation for the
entertainment it's all these different
compounds in the plant it's the
Turpin you know flavonoids or a number
of other cannabinoids the research is
just so young in this field that there's
a lot that's unknown yet so there's a
full spectrum of of chemicals and
compounds that go into the whole
experience it's not just best THC is
best time best medicine best best
anything so that's one thing that
influences this whole thing that's why
there is encouragement to to cheat to
get the highest THC levels for the
dollar amount in
involved
okay so what is lab shopping we let's
get right into it this is the phenomenon
we're talking about right it's a
situation that's grown over time from a
consumer demand you know highest THC
level of
flour um highest biggest high best value
right that's what they're trying to go
for um here we are in 2023 finding
there's more to it the science of the
other compounds are important but it's
this phenomenon where Growers producers
were encouraging
favoring you know going to Labs testing
things in multiple labs and going with
the lab that would give them the highest
results for whatever reasons whether
those are scientifically valid or not
that's where the whole thing about
cheating on a Level Playing Field comes
into play so again mostly this is flower
samples we're talking about it's just a
different little bit different type of
testing um and the variation is less
with these other products classes the
concentrates the oils the Edibles
Beverages and so forth um my experience
definitely says this you know there's
been unfair competition an unequal
playing field um there's an example
where you know Anonymous testing has
been done to compare six or seven labs
and I'll show you a slide in a second to
show what that looked like um results
from certain labs are you know outliers
on the high end of the range and you
know in a lot of cases these Labs will
out compete
legitimate scientifically
valid Laboratories and to the point of
hurting their business enough to to send
them toward heading out of
business here's a showing of some
example just some um THC data from
looking at 1 two 3 like six of the
cannabinoids right and the majority of
the labs are Labs one through there are
actually eight labs in this study the
majority of them were in a very tight
range
um however there's one if you look at
the red um boxes there was definitely
kind of an outlier lab there like lab
four which was producing consistently
inflated results compared to the rest of
the group so something is going on there
like that
you know that's
where there needs to be a system a
process in place where this kind of
thing can happen whether in different
situations like so how do we deal with
this this is you know the potentially
unfair advantage that we need to deal
with as as an industry to move it
forward move it more scientifically
valid and reproducible and Al also this
is very impactful on the consumer end
um
as you'll
see all right next I just want to go
into some of the ways that the data can
be manipulated a little
bit you know there are a lot of
variables at play
here to me probably the biggest one in
this whole phenomenon is one before it
uh testing takes place in the lab which
is basically accurate
sampling so it would be pretty
easy without doing it scientifically
properly to get higher THC values you
just pick the part of the plant the
sparkling part of the plant with the
most
tricomes and you have a good chance of
getting more of all the canono out so
the states write regulations try to uh
Force this to regulations are complex
and not really easy to understand and I
feel like in a lot of cases not followed
this is also very difficult ult one to
Monitor and enforce um because it's just
a sampling person at a collection site
and there are probably video cameras of
it of of the process but really beyond
that it's not track like something that
once it's inside the lab so it's the
quality of the sample in quality of the
result out
right another couple places where there
can be you know movement of the data
I'll say is inaccurately weighing or
reporting the weights of samples as
you're starting the
process another place where
manual override can take place is just a
little bit on the data quantitation and
Analysis
side and then you know there's been Labs
that I have no knowledge of this
personally I've not ever seen or heard
anything but outright manipulation of
data reported on coas I've heard things
like someone will ask for something and
then it will get delivered if needed so
that's what we're trying to contend with
and the more we can Veer toward the Hard
Solid science you know the better we're
going to be
so next I just want to touch on like
what are some consequences of this right
and I have kind of really touched on it
like for the industry in the field but
it goes beyond that it goes to our whole
Essence as a a valid industry right
consumer dose is is critical right so
people need solid numbers to know how
they're going to feel with these
different products and it's also not
just flower but they get a number they
feel like they can do something with a
flower sample and take it over to a
different type of product uh an edible
or a concentrate or something and if the
results of any of them are off
significantly they're not getting the
right information for themselves for
their health for their well-being that
kind of so it actually hurts the
confidence and the the sector as a whole
I think it hurts the investment in the
sector as a whole too this lack of
confidence and Trust in scientific
methods and the processes behind
it you know i' I've been in executive
management meetings where we had the
very hard decisions to make how do
we how do we deal with this we're
reporting results accurately to the best
of our knowledge and we're getting outc
competed by Labs that are not so couple
suggestions are one we maybe stop
testing for flour altogether it's not a
good situation but it's it's not a Level
Playing Field you're doing that and
you're also maybe making a little bit of
a statement you know you're and you're
hoping you can build a market on the
other type of testing it's not the way
to go um but it's one thing um people
are talking about maybe stopping testing
altoe for THC so there's any number of
things you know that have been discussed
um and the labs you know the labs are
frustrated the labs like it's a bread
and butter test everyone's potency test
it's a difficult test to run actually
the flour samples are the hardest they
actually are hardest on the instruments
they take more maintenance and more
cleanup due to the because there's so
many dense compounds in cannabis during
the testing
process so um I think lab labs would
prefer to just test other types of
products but I don't think that's a
sustainable model very difficult
Financial business model anyway that
these labs are in as I try to kind of
get
across all right and finally you know
what so where do we go right what are
what could we do from here and I have a
couple of suggestions um these things
will take time to evolve maybe some of
them will make sense some not as much
one thing is at the consumer level I
think better education is important like
we have to kind of get off of this most
THC for the least amount of dollars is
our best way to go there's more much
more to it than that and there's a lot
of complexity in it okay one thing is
the US federal government is not helping
anything here right they're very
confused that we have this Patchwork of
state
regulations uh it's really in this gray
Zone um safe banking has not passed
that's kind of hurt the entire field so
there's the us can help
on that front a big part of this I think
goes to the state Regulators though they
really need better
scientific understanding and enforcement
of the activities that are happening um
I mean the best as a scientist the best
way I would try to set it up is have a
state owned Reference Lab like actually
set up a lab in the maybe the largest
state maybe California I think this has
been tried there but uh to be able to
randomly um field test samples from
different Growers and different
Laboratories and compare results and see
like have a reference lab always have a
certified reference material if possible
and that includes like a lab testing
honestly so and then you know if there
that's one thing and then maybe other
states can borrow some of that capacity
or they figure it out like that or
multi-state model but something more um
on the regulator and and also there has
to be enforcement of
you
know the outliers or at least an
investigation to figure out where things
are and that they really need to be
serious consequences because you are
driving legitimate scientifically based
Labs out of the industry with with
letting this THC shopping go on
right and then I think at the lab level
you have to you know you have to hire
people have the
utmost uh Integrity a stake in a full
complete accurate transparent data set
like the best
scientist that should be the model that
takes us to the front um for the whole
field um so hopefully you know there's
change that can happen there I also
think there's more a lot more that can
be done on the you know chemistry side
the DNA diagnostic side with with
cannabis it's and again you have to
remember all this is in its infancy
because research is just
now you know fits and starts um starting
to ask starting to answer some of these
questions
so with that I want to thank you for
your time um I will just close and say I
appreciated the chance to speak with you
about this hopefully it was a little
thought-provoking I'm happy to talk
discuss anything a little further take
other questions or have a discussion on
this um and also available in this field
to help with with you know consultation
or research efforts um and I appreciate
your time thank thank you very
much